[Music]
this city finally opened up but kingside
banners is still not open which is a
really sad story for me but so hopefully
everyone is healthy and ready to look at
more scotch so last week I said I would
be showing you some games from Kasparov
and I did find two super cool games that
are one of my favorite ones from him as
well and another game of mind that was a
favorite one of mine as well but kind of
I have more opportunity but so I'm
hoping to get to all three games so if I
sound like I'm rushing a little because
I am but I will stop and give you time
to think about some of the critical
positions anyway and feel free to pause
and go back and forth on some of the
positions as well I'm also reading the
chats from right below so if I'm looking
down that's with me why hello everyone
who already 54 okay
so let's jump in to more scotch so the
first one I want to show you is a game
between Kasparov and it's teaming in the
year 2000 so this was actually a very
educational game for me last week we
looked at many nights of six lines and
so will we
I think two more of 96 this week as well
and one Bishop c5 but so we looked at
these lines last week and I showed you a
nice game that's I had the Tanya that's
she's one of my most favorites chess
players and so it was so cool for me to
get a win but so Bishop a6 is one of the
main lines and then the other
one is 96 so in this game
teaming just went with 96 and so there
are different variations on how to play
it's right here for white but Knight c3
is kind of like the most acceptable one
and so Queen e6 is again another line
there is a bishop a 6-2 but Queen e6 is
what C Mon plight and Kasparov late
Queen efore so now there is Bishop a six
and there is also a Bishop b4
I believe Bishop a6 was a game that
happened after this game Kasparov I want
to say Adams but if I'm wrong I
apologize already but that's would have
been Bishop basics so yeah here after
Bishop b4 move of double Bishop d2 is
logical because well first of all you
wouldn't want to get double double pawn
over here cuz your opponent's pawn
structure in that case would be stronger
than yours so you want to keep
protecting your pieces and your pawn
structure and so now Bishop a6 right
let's see first of all so c4 is under
attack we care about c4 we don't want to
lose it so b3 is the only logical move
to think about well let me rephrase that
b3 is definitely the most valuable
candidate to think about and after b3
you get the chance to have this pump
completely protected and so now know I
was right it is Kasparov Adams yes thank
you
fragrance okay so now the main thing
that you would have to worry about is
Bishop c3 Bishop c3 and d5 so this is
the first position that I'm
take a breather and ask you guys on what
do you want to do with white so yeah let
me know what you want to do with whites
do you want to take it on d5 do you want
to do some dances with the Queen
so yeah I'll be monitoring the chat so I
can hopefully tell you okay
so keeping those canned items and the
first two the main two that you should
do is take and well moving to clean
around clean ashore d4 maybe not
entirely sure about f4 but yeah ooh we
have in France oh hi you're nice
who is my favorite jam over the time
well Capablanca Fisher I think those two
are my top two most favorite ones the
rest I like am i grandmaster I am a
woman Grandmaster in an international
master that one more title to catch okay
so don't see much suggestions about the
position in the chat so I'm gonna just
go ahead and give them a move so Queen
h4 is the best one and well thank you
Joe
oh okay a lot of different countries
great alright so the thing is if you
were to take it over here you would
pretty pretty much automatically fix the
black's pawn structure and now you would
have to move your queen let's say
anywhere and you would also lose the
chance to cast them so that you don't
want that so you should move your queen
somewhere else and the best way to place
it as h4 and the reason is that after
Queen h4 after DC for even though it
looks like you would be losing upon
you're not really so yeah so the
question is after take there are triple
pawns what do you want to do I think
yeah I had a suggestion from Gil wolf
about before so before it's definitely
interesting but also rights knife is
black so move black is and that's going
to be able to take whips black won't
take because of the pin on the bishop so
you don't necessarily have to play
before so yeah maybe that's something to
consider
so now why to move what do you want to
do maybe think about developing
Castellon bringing some rooks up
long cast the whoa
I won't officially be two more long
castle it just feels like you're asking
for it long cast oh it's um now that
everything is super opened up the bees
opened up there is always going to be
risks you're never going to actually
take back no it's nope alright so after
Bishop e2 now you kind of have to think
about two main moves for black one of
them is cast oh and if you were to cast
those simple Castille the main thing is
since this pawn is no longer on d5 the
knight can jump to d5 and after that you
would simply have take and now this is
good position because if black were to
take here now these pawns are all going
to be targeted for the rest of the game
and if black tries to do anything else
Turk c1 it automatically or d1
automatically and why it's going to have
the upper hand so that's one thing that
castle would face and the other thing so
95 was played in the game between
Kasparov and team on and as we just saw
taking on c4 is the as possible
and so that's what Kasparov did the
other moves that are possible are like
something like Bishop d4 but Bishop t4
was going to be a little unpleasant cuz
of queen of five the other moves that
were played previously previous to this
game was something like c5 and the ninth
jumps a little there's gonna be bunch of
checks and I mean it's still playable
and quite pleasant it's a fair fight
basically but so this
instead of c5 queen f5 was a nude of new
new move that came up well 20 years ago
but Queen áfive was the reason this 54
wouldn't be so pleasant anymore
yeah so Bishop takes c4 now let's say
black tries to play frisky and play g5
because if black were to take take
and now c3 is defend it so if take take
that's again the same bleak pawn
structure that we mentioned before
and so g5 is waxed black like trying to
be tricky and trying to pick up pieces
Queen d4 is pretty much one of your only
two candidate moves so taking on d5 as
possible definitely and after Queen
takes you can pick this guy up but your
king is super wonderful like no never
going to Castle there could be a bunch
of checks there could be Queen D trees
just some unnecessary complications
there as with Queen D for everything
this seems to be safe and sound
so now black to move I want to ask you
what move would you want to play would
you want to take on c4 as black would
you want to take on C tree well maybe
not take on c3 but you can just try and
keep the bishop in the center or so yeah
just let me know what you want to do as
black alright so there is a question
from Rick heads generally do every
grandmaster let me move candy calculate
I don't think it's I don't think it's
that much about calculation the higher
level you get actually I've heard that
from a lot of player and it happened to
me too the less calculation you need
like
it's not like you can't you don't
calculate anymore it's more like you
have a feeling of the position your
instincts are sharpened enough that you
don't calculate every single move
you know this move is good and you don't
you use the your calculation to like
prove that this was good or this move
has to be eliminated but the one thing
that I've noticed beginners do is they
calculate so much unnecessary things
that they get a long time they lost they
lose their energy so yeah I hope that
answers your question but there's an
absolute answer I can't I mean some
people can it really depends on the
position if it's a super simple endgame
you can just keep calculating if it's a
very complicated middle game you have a
lot of different lines to calculate so
it's it's not more just about ten moves
it could be like ten different lines of
five movers or something like that but
yeah okay so Bishop d7 that's a
possibility but Bishop c4 in fact is
blacks best try because even if you were
to play Bishop d7 you're still never
going to take on c3 so let's say white
just castles and you can't even like
your castle is not even going to be safe
or something else that white could try
to do and make life a little bit hard is
like something with Bishop C Bishop b5
Bishop b4 and then like trying to put
the Bishop on c5 to just control
everything you won't be able to castle
anymore so that's another thing so yeah
Bishop d7 is definitely a candidate move
but after seeing just the position on
how unpleasant it is for black as black
the best move to do is to actually take
on c4 so the double pawn weakness is
inevitable
yeah that's one of the reasons that this
gang actually got a pretty cool end game
and that's one of the reasons why I like
this game a lot is because it shows you
how nice you can get to the end game and
alright so now again Knight c3 is going
to be quite unpleasant for black so
black tried lights for specially because
in this position blacks King is very
very unsafe so any chance that I could
have is within an endgame because if
black keeps the Queens in the game then
it's going to be very hard to protect
the King so 9 to 4 Queens exchanged now
why to move what do you want to do with
your King do you want to go this side do
you want to go at that side you just
want to put it on each you so please
just let me know
um what's move you would wants to play
with White's so I have a question from
Ben
yeah well so Bennett's it mainly depends
on how much time you have and how much
support you have because you gotta get
if you don't have enough time or enough
support it's going to be very hard to
actually well if you don't have time you
can't practice if you don't have the
support to practice if you have five
jobs and your student it's um you don't
have the necessary support so but yes it
is always possible to improve and that's
why we're here all right so long Castle
is actually the best one because you
this rope gotta get in the game and you
need to keep your king somewhere inside
of the game too because you don't want
to just tuck your King on each one and
go back and check up on it after a few
moves you want to keep the king close
enough that it's not an immediate danger
but it is close enough to be able to
form some sort of necessary attack and
support to get the king up so long
castle it is and you see now this trick
is gonna come can go after all those
lovely puns so those of you who also
watch our twitch channel know that I'm a
very religious pawn eater so seeing this
pawn attacks is warming my heart already
alright so black doesn't really know
what to do with the King cuz long castle
is illegal short castle doesn't make
much sense and so King g7 is what black
tries and now we try to bring the rook
up so my other question for you is it a
good time to exchange a pair of rooks or
would you want to just try to avoid it
by let's say Bishop d2 or well don't
have much option of ignoring it but
Bishop d2 kind of avoids rook exchange
so do you want to play like Bishop d2
and avoid exchanging roofs or do you
want to exchange the rooks
so shakunt sati your sisters ten years
old and she wants to start chess well
yeah definitely I think I mean if it was
like 20 years ago it would have been
much harder because it's like you would
have to find like specific books you
wouldn't know how to start but right now
there are a lot of opportunities
everything is online so yeah I do think
that she can how I would recommend
finding some first of all the first
thing you should be she should be
comfortable with within chess is the
squares and the pieces on how they move
so as long as she's comfortable with
those and it's like someone says g3 she
knows where g3 is that's going to be a
very nice stepping stone and then
there's 24/7 you can find someone who's
playing chess online and streaming about
it so that's one thing to do oh hi
Jillian yeah
taking exchanging the rooks it's good
yeah so exchanging the works in this
specific position is pretty good because
after you get district so out of the
position now these pawns are way more
vulnerable and now your rookie for plan
comes much smoother so here in this
position if black were to try something
with Knight to f4 to try and jump in
some checks on there you would still do
your routine for and you like blacks
pawns are just way too weak to be able
to pull anything off so black tries roof
d5 because if you were playing through
k4 is is still pretty cool and okay for
deserts chance too
be considered but you don't have to rush
it there is nothing that's going to take
that away so Kasparov played king c2
just to bring a little bit more pieces
in to keep the harmony and now I want
you to think about what black could
potentially do to try and see save some
of the pawns maybe because next move is
your K 4 and this Bishop is way too
strong protecting 'if I've given you no
chances Kasparov is white teaming is
black
how to register I well I I'm a little
lost in this question because there's so
many different chess websites chess calm
is one of the cool ones just 24 has a
lot of educational videos our channel
has so many different video contents for
any level so our twitch channel so maybe
give those websites a little tribe
okay so 95 possible but 95 doesn't do
much good because you can just go after
the other part and as soon as defense
you just go back and even if not defend
there's always potential Bishop be
forced to worry about cuz then Roxy 4
would be coming ok
King c2 c5 is actually the move that was
played and the idea is to try and
exchange the night with the bishop so
that we could get into an endgame and
the team on wanted to try his chances
for a broken game because you can't game
could potentially have chances that this
position doesn't because this Knight is
just very defensive alright so c5 work
goes to 84 keeping up with our plan
94 and now what do you want to do do you
want to take the knight or do you want
to let the knight stay here you move the
King from check and yeah just let me
know which move you would like to try
wait white
but yeah besides me who else is excited
for some high quality chess with cool
commentary from the club huh Claude
chess is happening in about a week so
hopefully you've all heard about it and
yeah it's really pretty cool not as cool
as actually seeing players over the
boards and having real life chess but
still cool with the situation well be
careful cuz you're under check so you
can't ignore that so playing something
like King b2 is possible but the problem
is something like herky 5 and stand Rafi
2 is jumping so we don't really want to
give that opportunity even if take take
take now Burke gets into the 2nd rank
and ouchy ouchy so you don't want to
give your opponent chances to gets his
position better so we take that tonight
and now we take that pawn and the cool
thing is if rook takes over here now
well first of all you could take and now
if jd6 you could even take the other one
and these two would be passed pawns hand
in hand and even if you somehow managed
to get your King to d3 that's also
another possibility I'm not the biggest
fan of planking d3 right now because
King d6 and you take there's still Ricky
- and it's much better to have that -
passed pawns rather than the other
things like check up take there's you
can just take and your two pawns up the
other one is falling this would be quite
pleasant to play with white so black
plays King d7
and the same way we've been talking
about king d tree now you get the chance
to actually do this King Gd tree and
your key five doesn't really pose that
threat anymore the turkey - cuz take and
Ricky - is a big threat and you can't
really save this palm so the best you
can do is keep that King Gandhi tree so
there won't be any more intruders to
your issue okay okay so let's say rook
takes on e5 now my question to you why
to move what do you want to do be
careful because if you take there's
going to be Ricky choose so little bits
of getting a little endgame warm up for
Dennis what is the link check it out
it's a tournament that is going to
happen with for us best players and our
super super cool commentary team it's
gonna be online so I'm a little excited
to see how that's going to work out
so a four is definitely interesting drew
a floor is definitely interesting I kind
of prefer drew k4 and so did Kasparov
because York's job here is kind of done
right now and you wanna come eat some
ponds and Roxy work a for the main thing
that you have to calculate the only move
logical for black to do is c5 now the
question for you is as white how do you
want to use this c5 you have a lot of
different options and that's good
because it means you have more chances
to start getting holes from your
opponent's so
g3 all right so I already had someone
answer this question it's going to be
hard for me to pronounce it but to shoot
to subbu Korra I tried
you are her ex before before is the best
one and very logical to write so giving
a check is definitely something that you
should think about but it kind of keep
pushes the king up and if the King gets
to d5 it's going to be quite unpleasant
for you and do it doesn't pose any
immediate threats if black were to M
just be able to save his pawns and get
the King on d5 it would be quite
unpleasant so before it is now if black
were to play King c6 you just take and
you play your FC for it this is a
winning pawn and King you have outside
pass pawn and if you've done a lot of
this in the King and warfare class that
we had on Twitch so this is winning this
pawn in the game is winning so the two
main rules to calculate for black is
King e6 and c4 because we always have to
take a look at possible checks so I
would like to you viewers to take a
little bit of time and calculate c4 and
King g6 and let me know which one would
you prefer to play or if you find
something cooler than these two let me
know and who go we will go over it so
yeah this clutch's is supposed to be
pretty cool and I'm not entirely sure I
don't know if that is confirmed but I've
heard that there could potentially be
more international
in June like this and they we do want to
be able to hold real-life tournaments
but it's just quite impossible right now
but nothing is nothing is canceled
everything is simply postponed for right
now so we are keeping our hopes up
all right let's see what do we have here
c4 definitely cool f5 alright so the
problem is if you were to play f5 simply
take and you would lose this guy
kingi d6 we just looked at king c6 so
it's similar to that alright so let's
take a look at c4 check so c4 check
change Thanks all right so hold on if c4
check do you think you should take on c4
or d4 that's a good question so yeah try
your best and yeah the idea is to try
and get on the second rank you're
correct Brian Clark so that kind of
answers it if white were to take King d4
there is Ricky - and this gives black
chances to find some wiggle room and
right now King c4 is the better one and
now you get the chance to try with your
case 5 - like cuts the king and attacks
on pawns there is a chance that Dirk a7
as well and trying to do rock a5 but
troop has to be on a5 to tack pawns and
to control the position better and after
okay 5 take take take take and it's a
good chance to win but black also gets
chances to for a better defense alright
so let's go back up up up all right so
that's c4
see four would be blacks best chance in
this position but black tried it King e6
and now what do you think white should
do should why take on c5 or should white
push I have seen the comments mix of
boats in the chat
Yaroslav said the king g6 takes a curve
takes t4 possible but I kind of think b5
is much better because now whoops well
check first and then b5 because now you
get the chance to have to pass pawns if
the King were to go to d5 you simply
have a k5 and you are going to try for
the endgame and that would be super
winning the opponent game is extremely
winning so no question is there
so if King got five now b5 let's say
rooks tries d5 some c4 check chances you
just take that and you take that and one
last one one last question for you guys
in this game why - what do you want to
do do you think Kasparov is losing maybe
a little bit reducing any tricks to win
this game for whites
so all right so I already have a no-no -
what
all right good everyone sees j4 nice
proud of everyone g4 is the key move so
take you get check and rook comes and
defends the Queen so it is quite
important to be able to see this after
you can keep waking c4 coz if King c4 d3
if you didn't have that g4 let's say if
your opponent's pawn was actually on g4
you would be a little bit um not to say
stuck yeah let's go with that so it is
very important to calculate in this
position remember how earlier I said not
necessarily every move you have to
calculate everything well right now you
do because you see the opponent wants to
place C 4 and after c4 d3 would be
possible so if you couldn't see rook c6
then move you have to play is something
like her a tree or rook c6 is okay and
then if you don't see this last move g4
then you would hear you would simply
take with the rook and it is still you
still have advantage to not that it's
not like a super advantage but it's
advantage and this is still very fight
able White has the upper hand so just if
you don't see everything like if you
don't see that last g4 don't play don't
play it alright so this is the first
game that I wanted to show you I don't
think we will get to the other Kasparov
game because well I am trying to talk
fast but still it's not going as fast as
it's [ __ ] okay so now I want to show you
a game of myself that it was baby dorsum
not to baby I was 16
and I was this is 2014 I was hunting
done wim norms who need who needs those
right now right and kidding everybody
needs every title but this was I think
my first oh yeah it was my first time
traveling alone and in politican cup and
denmark so shout out to that i was
pretty cool and now it wasn't when I got
the bad time Drive
it's I got the bathtub drive last year I
don't know where it came from actually
and all right so let's get to this game
this was I remember last round of the
helsingor tournament pull the chicken
cup that's actually where I played
Alejandra Ramirez the current slew coach
and I lost horribly but well I'm here
now here's my coach have a nice
scholarship I can't let go of that one
loss right okay so this game is I play
it again Xander vision that Solomon I
want to say Johnson Johan oh my bad
still oops John same it's not the same
all right
he I'd believe he's a grandmaster now
and so this was kind of quite odd
pleasant for him for me the little girls
to take a draw out of him but stuff I
gave what the results already good
anyways so this was a fun scotch I
haven't shown you anything in Bishop c5
last week or this week so should be fun
to look at this I really like this night
b3 Knight c3
five cuts recommendation to play this
when I was kid actually actually a kid
like 2010 and I like it and I've been
doing it ever since I mean I mix up but
night Petrie is still my favorite ones
the idea is quite simple I put the
on e 2 and if you cancel too fast I'll
do this Bishop g5 if you don't do that
then I'll just play like simple Bishop
III mastery cast oh oh space attack if
I'm not wrong 2014 it's been a long time
so memory can get a little foggy but I
do you think that parry margin Negi had
a nice like series on chess base that's
really helped me so if you want to
copy-paste me that's where I got most of
my Intel but I could still be wrong and
it could not be there anymore so but
that's where I remember it was six years
ago getting old okay so Queen e2 he
tried to talk with cast on and then just
Bishop g5 my idea was simple if you were
to try and play h6 I would be so happy I
would do this Bishop e3 and I would
simply do the long castle and now I have
a full target on h6 to go after later on
so that's something that you can't try
to provoke your opponents with Bishop g5
so he tried Knight d4 - okay one thing
to keep in mind is Lupe's taking makes
it a little uncomfortable cuz now your
king is all opened up a little so
that's why Queen d2 is the best move
take heed simply take back with the a
pawn and now a question for you guys
what do you want to do do you feel like
playing get some fun stuff at h4 I'm not
saying you shoot them just asking you or
do you want to just play Bishop III back
like what we were talking about a little
bit before and I'm going to look in the
chat there's a question from Victor any
defense for efore there are many
defenses for e4
caro-kann French d5 Sicilian neither F
there are a lot of things you just have
to find what feels right to you Bishop
III yeah cuz keep it normal not no time
to get freaky alright hey Reed Bishop e3
after Bishop e3 Bishop f6 also okay so
the thing is if you have more pieces you
could definitely think about sacrificing
but you don't have any pieces in the
attack caps except for the Queen
so it wouldn't be very logical to try
and do that so yeah Vishal h4 is also a
possibility but Bishop is for it's kind
of on the way for your pawns because you
want to start upon March alright so I
did this Bishop e3 and now he wants to
play d5 if it's black sin with blacks
playing d5 so long castle to stop d5
d6
there's a question if fish for wood
would be possible to play nice efore ooh
my initial thought was something with
Queen afore but I don't think that works
so yeah I guess that's why actually yeah
good I I was thinking
initially I thought Queen afore and if
you play Knight f6 that's just perfect
but now I see there could be a lot of
different potential ideas first of all
if I play g5 what do you do because it
take there is your key eight so yeah
this one is for um doesn't it just feels
wrong I to me I don't like to have my
pieces hanging because it's gives
opponent chances to go after them so I
always want to have them protected by
something else so to me Bishop e3 comes
naturally but I see why Bishop is for
Whitney's drew more attention all right
so yeah okay so Castille now d6 so
remember how I was telling you about
forming an attack with f3 g for now it's
the time you get your g4 outs you get
your h4 out so here I was quite happy I
was like everything is going good my
position is lovely and pushing pawns now
it is white it is black soon moving
black played g5 and I was just like why
man why would it take away my g5 and the
simple answer is cuz g5 actually wasn't
the best move for black but the problem
for me was that I understand that I have
to take it and that was a good thing
because if you were to play h5 you would
kind of be closing it up so taking is
the best one here I decided to be
normal and develop with Bishop c4 which
was not the best move so now I am going
to ask you what do you think is the best
move for whites and no it's not
something super crazy
yeah I mean you're correct you shouldn't
really move the pawns on that side all
right yeah might be 595 Wow
cool you're very fast to super cool
hi I'm still trying on the pronunciation
so now if I was actually super strong
and that idea is if you were to play
Rocky 7 I would just do rook 94 and next
move I might try Knight f5 might be
because if I got to this Knight a5 idea
then this pawn would be super super weak
so that's something that would be really
Pleasant for me and all right so after
94 blacks buzz tribe would be something
with 95 because queena 4 and the end
game would be more pleasant for white
because I can just take on a 4 and put
the Knights back on e 2 and pick up the
pond least of all so 9520 to you to try
Knight up for now you do your Bishop c4
or you can try with Queen it to now
White has a very organized attack you
got the Queen on h2 the knight on d4 is
way better than it was on c3 Bishop c4
is coming next and this is the way I
should have went about it but I didn't
so let's go back to Bishop c4
so I played this Bishop c4 and after
Bishop c4
he played Bishop e6 I took which I think
I should have played King bee one just
because it provides more because black
is going to try and push some pawns
so this would give me the chance to keep
it all tied up all right
so take take now I realize that I do
want this night to be in the text so I
tried to deny teach you I did the King
be one because it was necessary I did
the night g3 now question for you do you
think my g3 is good cuz right now I
don't
in the game I did
all right
oh that's a good clothes
okay so why to move who wants to do what
what do you guys want to do
yeah you are right for is the better try
I'm kind of curious what is your rating
um tasuku Cora I'm still trying never
been the strongest in pronunciation yeah
so Knights g3 is not actually that that
good f4 is the best one and after take
my take White has good advantage but I
didn't realize this over the board and I
missed my chance so I went with my g3 my
idea was to play Knight h5 take it take
my idea was to play whoops 935 take my
take with the drunk and I double my
rooks and I have this whole that
everything super Pleasant but there is a
devilish ricocheted that stops it all
and after we catch eighth night h5
didn't really work anymore
now black to move what do you think I
should do my opponents found a very nice
move and that kind of stopped us
oh nice 2,200 yeah I was gonna say
somewhere at least 2100 but all right
you're good well glad you're here and
enjoying it yeah fragrance your corrects
King gauge six and so the idea is after
King gauge six my attack is kind of
stops even when I try to bring more
pieces I simply don't have enough attack
to put up we went when doubling up even
when trying to bring more pieces it's
just not enough so I tried the different
angle and yep exactly it's was rest in
peace to my attack and now I was the one
getting a little bit attacked but I
tried to be a little tricky and go to
the eighth rank which seemed like a nice
idea and now it's white to move and I
realized that if I do try to go to the
endgame it's not going to be that
Pleasant because there is going to be
this rook f1 and this is going to be
quite painful at least in the endgame so
I didn't really want to get into a war
cent game so I try to keep the game
alive keep my Queen alive with something
like Quincy AIDS but right now black is
a slightly better because my attack is
pretty much dead and he did this trick
f1 check and now my king is in a very my
king as well sort of safe but at the
same time it's not really doing much so
after this he just wants Queen of Six to
protect King as I was saying Queen g6
mates and now I still tried to fight
with Queen e8 because also another
threat is York is eight so Queen e8 was
sort of necessary
so if ricocheted I would have 27 I'm
still trying to poke around and see if
there is anything in the position and he
did slight repetition I did district g3
because I was hoping to get some ruckus
trees and
[Music]
I think here I finally managed to get a
perpetual yeah because here after Queen
afore I got the chance to go with Queen
g8 and I got this perpetual because even
if the Queen goes back to f6 I can just
go back with Queen eh
and he didn't know how to advance his
position so that was something that was
nice I kind of the idea of going behind
the king was pretty smart
because I realized my attack is dead and
I didn't really like the quantum
structure everything was a little wobbly
so it was pretty cool to be able to get
this drop and end the tournament on a
nice note and yeah so that's the two
games that I showed you today I hope you
enjoyed the Kasparov game and the door
side game so tune in for Dennis right
after me and they are feel free to post
your comments after and I do come and
check it afterwards so if you have any
questions let me know
yeah well thank you and have a nice day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you